you know what I love I love when you're
sitting down thinking today's going to
be a relaxing day I'm just going to
watch one of the Harry Potter movies to
prepare for my upcoming Harry Potter
reviews and then a trailer for the
upcoming Wonder Woman movie gets
released so I guess that's going to be
put on the backburner
Comic Con has tons of surprises and one
of them this year is that we get a
Wonder Woman trailer I genuinely had no
idea they were this far along and
filming in fact they're done filming
it's in post-production I had no idea
this movie was actually coming out next
year that's how hurtful loop I am with
all this stuff but that's cool so let's
talk about this trailer does it look any
good normally I don't do trailer review
so much anymore unless it's for a very
big movie the reason I'm doing this one
is because this is a character that
intrigues me I'll be honest with you I
really don't know much about the Wonder
Woman character when it comes to the
comics this is a comic series that I
have not really delved into yet my
exposure to this character is limited to
the old TV show with Lynda Carter when I
was a kid I used to watch reruns of it
and the Justice League animated cartoon
which was tons of fun
so this trailer opens up with Chris Pine
washing up on shore and Wonder Woman
Diana Prince played by gal gadot a
little bit confused by the fact that
he's a man a very rare thing for her
where she's from and one of the things
that I like about this trailer right off
the bat is that it actually looks fun
that's something I think that DC
Universe needs some fun some energy some
excitement and this trailer definitely
looks like it's going to bring that this
movie's going to be directed by patty
Jenkins who made the movie monster a
very good film with Charlize Theron and
Christina Ricci but also a very
different movie from Wonder Woman which
is this big studio action blockbuster
movie so I'm reserved about that because
it is such a big leap from a smaller
film to a bigger film but for directors
like Christopher Nolan in the past who
came from films like memento and
insomnia then went into Batman Begins
that was obviously successful what I
want out of a Wonder Woman movie as
someone who isn't necessarily initiated
with her comics is kick-a Suri and this
trailer definitely provides that imagery
because there are a ton of sequences of
her just laying down the law left and
right and manda
look good I'm actually surprised how
much footage I saw her kick and ass in
this trailer because I wasn't expecting
that much so that tells me one of two
things either there is a ton of it in
this movie and she is just beaten down
people every other minute or I just saw
way too much
that's something I'm concerned about
with every trailer I watch and one of
the biggest reasons I haven't done as
many trailer reviews lately is because
trailers tend to spoil a lot and I've
actually started to not watch quite a
bit of trailers unless it's something
humongous like Wonder Woman or say road
one but when it comes to this trailer I
had a great time with it Chris Pine
looks funny gal gadot looks fantastic as
Wonder Woman the world looks good I also
really like the color scheme which is
something I don't think has been focused
on enough the past few DC Comics movies
we have gotten have been very
desaturated and kind of grayscale
looking I like the fact that this movie
looks colorful it looks bright it looks
exciting it looks like it's fun that's
what I want out of a Wonder Woman movie
I don't need to have her moping around I
don't need to have her crying I don't
need sad face Wonder Woman I want a
badass heroine who's out there kicking
ass having fun and this movie looks like
it's going to deliver that and I'm
hoping that the final product is good
because as you know in the long run
trailers don't mean shit the real
product is the movie and this is looking
optimistically like a good one and I'm
excited about that what are your
thoughts on the new Wonder Woman trailer
did you guys check it out let me know
below thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes